[Music]
fantastic yeah I thought the audience
didn't you know people sometimes don't
know that I'm Indian so because of my
white skin and my great American accent
I thought I would wear something
traditional from home this is like our
Indian like an inn you know it's our
suit it's like the Indian that's your
suit it seems much more convenient than
our suit you just it is put it on and
then you're dressed up for any occasion
I look like the Indian Darth Vader or
something it's a long time ago so much
to talk about how is your married life
last time I was talking to you you're
about to get married you've been married
a very short time yes well I mean
depends how you look at it in this town
it seems like it's been quite a while
yes in Los Angeles yeah six months
counts for like 15 years
exactly it's been going great we just
adopted a puppy
which has been wonderful except it never
really it makes me into it makes me
never to want to have children I know
that sounds why don't order me like I'm
seeing a terrible thing to say hello the
puppy makes you not wanna have children
because you know I'm exhausted of waking
up at 6:00 in the morning and being and
pooping this thing and it's just it's
exhausting well well first of all it's
much different when you have a real
child they pee and poo much more often
you haven't you haven't met my puppy man